we're told that roberto and jocelyn
decide to roll a pair of fair six-sided
dice to determine who has to dust their
apartment
if the sum is seven then roberto will
dust if the sum is 10 or 11 then jocelyn
will dust if the sum is anything else
they'll roll again
is this a fair way to decide who dusts
why or why not so pause this video and
see if you can figure this out before we
do it together
all right now let's do this together so
what i want to do is make a table that
shows all of the different scenarios for
rolling two fair si two
fair six sided dice
so let me make columns for roll one
so that is
you get a one this is when you get a two
this is when you get a three this is
when you get a four
this is when you get a five and then
this is when you get a six
and then here
let's do it the other die so this is
when you get a one this is when you get
a two
this is when you get a three
this is when you get a four
this is when you get a five and then
this is when you get a six
so one way to think about it is
this is
roll one or let me write it this way die
one and die two this could be a one a
two a three a four a five or a six and
this could be a one a two a three a four
a five or six
now we could do is fill in these 36
squares to figure out what the sum is
actually let me just do that and i'll
try to do it really fast one plus one is
two so it's three
four five six
seven this is three four five six seven
eight this is four five six seven eight
nine this is five
six seven eight nine ten this is six
seven eight
nine ten eleven last but not least 7 8 9
10 11 and 12 took a little less time
than i suspected all right let's think
about this scenario if the sum is 7 then
roberto will dust so where is the sum 7
so we have that ones
twice 3 times 4
5 6. so 6 out of so 6 of these outcomes
result in a sum of 7 and how many
possible equally likely outcomes are
there well there are six times six
equally possible outcomes or 36.
so six out of the 36 or this is another
way of saying there's a one-sixth
probability that roberto will dust
and then let's think about the 10s or
11s if the sum is 10 or 11
then
jocelyn will dust
so 10 or 11. so we have one
two
three
four
five
so this is only happening five out of
the 36 times so in any given role it's a
higher probability that roberto will
dust than josslyn will does and of
course if neither of these happen
they're going to roll again but on that
second roll there's a higher probability
that roberto will dust then joslin will
dust so in general this is not fair
there's a higher probability that
roberto dusts so this is our choice